[Musique]
les législatives approchent les
électeurs éliront leurs députés les 12
et 19 juin prochain tv 60,18 vous aide à
y voir plus clair et vous dresse les
enjeux du scrutin dans chacune des 12
circonscription des yvelines ce soir et
directions direction la 5e
circonscription avec patrice carmouze
bonsoir directeur de l'information de tv
78 déjà géographiquement où se trouve
cette 5ème circonscription
la seconde dans le nord-est du
département si on réussit les scellés
ville de maisons-laffitte sartrouville
le vésinet le mesnil le roi est monté
son
c'est une circonscription quatre
législatures a été celle de du maire de
maisons laffitte jacques myard celui qui
était un gaulliste vos couleurs
assez souverainiste alors on pensait
qu'il allait peut-être être réduit en
2010 7 et u va sauver cette cette vague
macro disent t ils étaient emportées par
par cette vague mais c'est une avocate
qui a été élu à sa place qui est yale
brawn pie v qui est une ancienne membre
d'ailleurs du parti socialiste viable à
gauche alors ayez le bon driver est
devenue une mort à porto de la majorité
macro nice telle est la présidente de la
commission des lois qu une commission
importante c'est à dire la première
femme présidente d'une commission qui
n'avait jamais été élu député avant et
c'est juste la deuxième femme présidente
de la commission des lois la première
c'était une autre élu dans les yvelines
qui avait été ministre de mitterrand
c'était catherine tasca et donc phase
iia les branles verts on retrouve trois
femmes trois femmes et trois femmes
importantes la première c'est alexandra
du blanche et conseillère régionale qui
est a dit au maire de sartrouville qui
est très proche de valérie pécresse
d'ailleurs la côtoient ou au conseil
régional
elle bénéficie d'une bonne image de
femme dynamique bien implanté
régionalement et localement
et puis une petite anecdote qui est
assez amusante vaut celle qu'on a
beaucoup parlé de mckinsey pendant la
campagne présidentielle tour leur
prochain maintenant ben alexander dit
blanche elle a commencé sa carrière chez
chez make it c'est vraiment ça donne
c'est un petit détail qui a son
importance le son problème c'est de
savoir à mal si elle va pâtir du mauvais
score de valérie pécresse aux
présidentielles si elle veut pouvoir se
détacher ce sera toute la question de
qui va se poser pendant sept dans cette
circonscription et qui sont les autres
candidats patrice alors à gauche pour la
nouvelle l'union populaire c'est une
mort de l afic et sophie thévenet sophie
thévenet elle avait déjà été candidate
en 2017 au lave a obtenu 1 8 25% des
voix mais là il donnait son top est
différente puisque jean luc mélenchon à
la grande surprise à la surprise
générale a été le premier à sartrouville
et la dune 34% des voix à sartrouville
donc
pas suffisant pour lui permettre d'être
élu mais peut-être qu'elle peut rêver à
créer la surprise et pourquoi pas à la
figure au 2e tour et puis côté et rennes
c'est aussi une femme qu on puisse et
une députée européenne matip nord drouet
qui sera candidate alors là le r n est
pas très très fort dans cette
circonscription donc on peut penser que
c'est surtout une candidature de
témoignage de la part de matignon merci
patrice carmouze pour ces précisions
[Musique]